now the british government is in turmoil
after two of its most senior ministers
resigned from prime minister boris
johnson's cabinet finance minister rishi
sunak said in a statement he no longer
saw eye to eye with johnson and that
their views on the economy were
fundamentally too different health
secretary sajid javid said he could no
longer continue in his role in good
conscience he said the conservative
party were no longer popular or
competent
boris johnson was forced to apologize
once again on tuesday that's after he
failed to come clean about what he knew
about an mp who was appointed to a
senior position despite claims of sexual
misconduct
well let's get more on this from rory
challenge in london
rory it looks
from the outset as if this could be the
start of a revolt against prime minister
boris johnson
he is hanging by a thread now the
british prime minister um
these are mortal uh blows to him we will
have to see whether they really do
finishing him off or whether he can
stagger on for a while this is a man a
politician who is renowned for being
almost lazarus-like able to to come from
uh the dead but we'll have to see this
is uh looking very very very precarious
for boris johnson for one uh key
minister to go is obviously a blow for
two to go in what is obviously
an orchestrated move uh
could well be the beginning of the end
boris johnson has been sucker punched by
first his health secretary and then uh
even more seriously by
his chancellor of the exchequer as well
we have both of the
letters that were written to boris
johnson by those ministers here and i
can read you
the first one this came from uh sajid
javid
who says that conservatives at their
best are seen as hard-headed
decision-makers guided by strong values
we've may not always have been popular
but we've been competent in acting in
the national interest
sadly in the current circumstances the
public are concluding that we are now
neither
the votes of confidence last month
showed that a large number of our
colleagues agree it was a moment for
humility grip and a new direction i
regret to say this is the key bit i
regret to say however that it is clear
to me that this situation will not
change under your leadership and you
have therefore lost my confidence too so
that is obviously a very very personal
attack uh on the prime minister wounding
him uh very deeply and then
we have the letter from sajid that's
from uh rishi sunak sorry the the
chancellor of the exchequer who says
the public rightly expect government to
be conducted properly competently and
seriously i recognize this maybe my last
ministerial job but i believe these
standards are worth fighting for and
that's why i'm resigning i'm sad to be
leaving the government but i've
reluctantly come to the conclusion that
we cannot continue like this both of
these ministers basically pointing the
finger at boris johnson saying that he
is the problem it's his personality it's
his leadership that is costing the
conservative party that is eroding trust
in the government and that's why they
have decided to leave a very very
serious blow for from for the prime
minister tonight
rory and this appears to be the
cumulative effect of scandal after
scandal i probably internationally our
audience knows about partygate but there
have been some dubious appointments uh
to senior posts within government
recently and the loss of two
by-elections recently talk us through
boris johnson's bumpy road over the past
couple of years
yeah well part again is the most serious
it's the one uh that has uh caused the
most headlines and has perhaps done most
to erode public trust in this government
and in boris johnson essentially boris
johnson was fined by the police uh along
with more than 100 of his aides and
civil servants
for partying uh through lockdown
at a time when he personally was telling
people around the country that they
should be staying at home they should be
not seeing loved ones
they could not even go into
old people's homes and say goodbye to
grandmothers grandfathers brothers and
fathers who who were perhaps dying um
they couldn't go and say goodbye to
people in hospitals
this was deeply deeply traumatic for the
country and uh to to find out that the
prime minister himself had been going to
parties while all that was going on
perhaps has done more than anything else
to damage his reputation but of course
there are other things as well there was
the owen patterson affair which really
poisoned relations i think with many of
his uh back benches now he was a former
tory minister who was found by the
parliament's standards watchdog to have
committed an egregious breach of
lobbying rules boris johnson then tried
to change those rules to protect
his friend and there was a backlash
which forced him to climb down there was
another scandal involving him decorating
his flats and who paid for that uh
whether that was a kind of cash uh for
favors sort of arrangement and most
recently uh the affair over chris
pincher which has been uh blowing up
this week uh
an mp a deputy whip who was found to
have committed uh
sexual misconduct
downing street said that boris johnson
didn't know anything about this it then
transparent transpired that he did and
earlier on today he came out and was
forced to apologize for yet another
of his
seeming gaffes or crisis let's listen to
how boris johnson put that earlier on
there's no place in this government for
anybody who
is predatory or who
abuses their position of power did you
want to joke though pincher by name
pinscher by nature well what i can tell
you is that uh
if i look at the background of this and
why i regret it so much is that uh
about three years ago uh there was a
complaint made against uh chris pincher
in the foreign office uh the complaint
was was uh
cleared up he apologized uh it was
raised with me
uh in uh orally there was a i was i was
briefed on what had
had happened and
you know if i had my time again
i would think back on it
and uh rory boris johnson seems to have
turned surviving political scandal into
something of an art form uh hasn't he in
the last few minutes or so
we've seen on social media confirmation
from liz trust the foreign secretary
that she will stand firmly behind the
prime minister kwasi kwateng the
business secretary and pride home
secretary and ben wallace defense
secretary all saying that they'll stand
by boris johnson there is still a chance
that he could survive all this
yeah i'll add jacob rees-mogg to that as
well uh i'll read you a
a quote from him the prime minister won
a mandate from the british people and
that is more powerful than cabinet
ministers resigning so clearly he does
still have supporters
but
the question is what he does now uh can
he rally those supporters will they be
enough to keep him in his position
will there be more resignations if there
are other big fish from within uh the
cabinet that who resign then that will
heap more pressure on him
will
there be a renewed attempt by back
benchers and those disenchanted with
boris johnson's leadership within the
conservative party to try to force
another vote of confidence the rules of
the game as set by the 1922 uh committee
are that once you have had a vote of no
confidence against you which he had very
recently and survived there cannot be
another one for a year but those rules
are changeable and
if the 1922 committee decides that it
wants to change the rules they can do so
they can reduce that statute of
limitations so there is a mechanism
perhaps that could be brought into play
again to try and get boris johnson out
out of power
that might be by the by though because
if we see more cabinet resonation
resignations his position may become
untenable anyway
well we challenged in london on a
dramatic day in british politics okay
well let's uh bring in uh sir john
curtis now who's the politics professor
at the university of strathclyde he
joins us from the french village of
mosse thank you so much for your time
sir john um
is it possible to say is this the
beginning of the end for boris johnson
if we look at the numbers
well it certainly looks as though it's
going to be difficult for him probably
the crucial thing now is even if no
other cabinet minister resigns what
happens
in the election that's due to take place
i think it's next week uh for the
officers of the 1922 committee that's
the
uh
the organization that represents
conservative backed ventures
there was already expected to be an
attempt to put in place in those
positions
those who would be willing to
contemplate holding another vote in less
than the 12 months you've just been
talking about
there must now be an increased chance
that an attempt to fill those posts with
those who don't want boris johnson will
succeed
and there must now have been increased
chances if there is another ballot
the second time around boris johnson
will not have
the majority behind him because
certainly i think the resignations of
rishi sunak and of sasha javid is going
to take some of the back benches and
perhaps in private other ministers
with them so
boris johnson is we know is very very
unlikely to resign he will attempt to
fill the two vectors that exist and the
fact that liz trusts the foreign
secretary has decided to stand by him
probably means he's at least okay for
the next 24 hours but
it's pretty clear that those mps who
were disenchanted with boris johnson two
weeks ago
or even more disenchanted now and the
question is to what extent do those two
cabinet resolution designations
act as a litmus test of increased
concern amongst mps who two weeks ago
were willing to give them the benefit of
the dart but perhaps perhaps are no
longer willing to do so
this is a man of course who swept to
power uh promising to get brexit done
and he's managed to sustain a tremendous
amount of popularity amongst the public
amongst mps for a tremendous amount of
time irrespective of scandal after
scandal but what sense are you getting
from the polls about its popularity
amongst ordinary voters
well the truth is you can easily
exaggerate as i think you've just done
the popularity of of boris johnson as
prime minister boris johnson yes
appealed to that half of the public that
voted leave
but he's never been popular amongst that
half of the public that voted uh remain
and his problem is however is that now
by no means all but some of those who
voted for him in 2019 um after having
voted leave i know we're longer willing
to stand by him so if you take the most
recent reading of whether people are
satisfied or dissatisfied with his
leadership you've got about 30 of the
general public saying they're satisfied
with him but over 50 saying they are
dissatisfied the numbers have been
around that level now for a number of
weeks and they essentially reflect the
damage that's been done to his personal
reputation
uh by in particular the partygate affair
now you know it's true there are still
people out there who go you know i'm not
quite sure boris has been telling us the
truth
um i certainly don't think he should
have been attending those gatherings in
10 downing street but who are still
willing to say he's delivered brexit he
delivered the vaccine rollout etc but in
the end this is i think become a story
that's moved on from the public reaction
the public reaction
really was set in stone six months ago
when the party got a story first broke
this is now really a feeling about tory
mps and i think it's always been the
case
that whether boris johnson could survive
would depend on the willingness the
continued willingness of his tory mps to
be willing to defend him on
al jazeera on the bbc on sky news etc
and just to give you one indication this
afternoon that i picked up that perhaps
tory mps are no longer willing to back
boris johnson just speaking to a local
radio bbc station based in coventry
they'd rang around all their
conservative mps trying to get one of
them to comment and none of them would
come on air and in the end it's the
question of whether or not tory mps
either because of an actual concern or
because of basically ethical concerns
about the prime minister whether they're
willing to defend him or not and the way
in which some ministers were
left to try to defend the prime minister
in the last 72 hours only to discover
that the
defense that they would give and prove
not to be the truth he's not going to
encourage other conservative mps uh in
uh any continued willingness to stand by
the prime minister now clearly
conservative mps are very much
keen to to hold on to their jobs going
forward but do you think all of this all
of these
shenanigans these ups and downs by the
prime minister have dealt a damaging
blow to the wider conservative party
well
i'm not sure that this story is going to
do any more damage to the conservatives
than particularly has already done i
mean the reason why this story has
lengths is because of the way in which
as you were discussing it it echoes the
concerns about the prime minister that
the owen paterson affair and the
partygate affair uh already had and the
partygate affair either isn't a
westminster bubble affair this is
something that touched a lot of people
emotionally because they knew what they
had to do during the lockdown the
sacrifices they made some of them deeply
personal ones and then they discovered
that in their view the prime minister
wasn't wasn't keeping to it that's where
the damage arose because in the wake of
that
people were saying hey
do i trust this gentleman's judgment and
b and crucially
do i believe what he says anymore 75
percent of the public have been saying
for weeks they do not believe what the
prime minister has been saying about
party gates and the question that's been
facing the conservative mps ever since
that is well they don't believe the
prime minister over partygate will they
believe him over the cost of living
crisis the ukraine crisis and the other
very very substantial challenges that
face this government if the prime
minister's no longer got the cr
credibility in the eyes of a significant
section of the public then recovery from
the party's current position under his
leadership was going to be difficult now
maybe we are not going to find out
whether you can turn things around but
that certainly was a big question
hanging over whether or not conservative
mps would be wise in uh keeping him as
their leader
sir john curtis political professor at
the university of strathclyde i'm sure
you'll be watching these political
developments very closely thank you
you're welcome